what up people hope you like john's
chucky impression from the other day oh
golly guys yeah we are late to this
chucky episode seven seven it's the
penultimate episode from what i
understand oh really
write conflicting reports but i guess
it's eight
well shoot yeah we're gonna shoot this
on wednesday
but uh i got really sick i go into the
urgent care and everything got all the
tests
but i'm
doing better now so yes i forget to see
you guys late we appreciate if you could
hit that like button though
mean the world and also subscribe and
click the notification bell to get
notified when our reaction to the finale
is up also um full length watch long
story stick up with the time code it's a
page you know this crap sub patreon and
then eric over at nerdcon thanks for
writing these down let's watch this
what a piercing photograph
yeah it's not a very flattering center
photo
it's like staring through your soul
i found out why my mom showed up that
night
someone called her he said i was in
trouble
hope i was here
it was shark oh oh no
why is chucky killing her parents
why is he rubbing it in our faces
because he's a dick
he gets off on this
we can still do this no jake
we're not good together
oh
maybe he's right
maybe we should just
go home for now you happy now
junior you ruin everything everyone
around you dies my mom devin's mom even
your own parents
it's junior stop that's none of your
business
i'm sorry about your mom this is not
jake's fault
junior
second i thought he was going to punch
her
what now
oh
yeah
oh god
oh you bold a woman
i'm so sorry
what the hell
yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry too
was that jennifer tilly
jennifer tilly knows my name
i said no cigarettes
i'm gonna need him if you're driving
these things are gonna kill you
definitely got us oh
nice thank you you're welcome
big sis always looking out
i wonder how 10 year old alex vincent
would feel knowing that andy barkley
grows up to be a
semi-badass
what
[Music]
ha ha very funny open the door
over the
maybe not the first time this has
happened
no caroline is your sister i'm doing
this for your own kid
chucky's already starting to rub off on
you
uh
i'm worried about you
you don't have to worry about me
i'm not gonna be around much longer
i wanna stay with my aunt for like a
week
she can't take care of me forever
where are you gonna go
junior's house
i've thought about running away
yeah
lots of times after my mom died what
stopped you
you
go jake oh
being around you
hurts
all i can think about when i
see you is
what she looked like
lying there
damn that sucks
um maybe i could come back another time
or
no
yes that's not gonna be gone in a couple
days
just wait for that chucky
there he is
oh no
this is a good
no
great day for hackensack our only task
now is to put this whole ugly affair
behind us and to start healing as a
community oh god charity matinee
of the universal classic
[Laughter]
a very special celebrity guest will be
joining us tomorrow to host an auction
prior to the screening so get them
jennifer for tilly
do you want to be mayor one day just
like your mommy
we asked you a question caroline
chucky told me to kill mommy
mayor cringe upstaged in a single
instant
the distorted blur lens reflecting this
man's own personal state of intoxication
of the year
mom always said he was
trying his best
he thinks oh he's clever
that's the thing man
chucky is an arch sadist
my mom is
dead your dad can be too
some people just deserve to die
dad's
ex-girlfriends
cousin
you knew it you got guts kid
no his dad's gonna be so nice to him now
isn't he you know i've been thinking you
don't have to run track
if only you stayed like two seconds long
just can't help it
oh yeah
that'll taste the [ __ ] out of that house
making your favorite smoothies meatballs
chucky having affair
is he killing someone without me
you're killing without
that's exactly idea but killing is an us
thing
don't wait up for me red
it's
swedish meatballs
your father's favorite
what i know you
aren't you a little young to seem bound
what were you doing there with my dad
is chucky trying to get him to kill her
oh no no i've
i've said too much already oh [ __ ]
what a diabolical plan are there in
cahoots
[Laughter]
god the push and pull on this kid
who is that
help me
oh
no
oh i hope you don't die man
where are you taking that
i can't tell you that
987 sherwood lane
hi
i'm billy you want to play
you imagine good guys like
advertising on influencer videos
[Music]
take it to 987 sure woodland
can you please help me
you can be perfect
[Music]
let's give you some water
oh no
my name's devon by the way
what's yours
oh it depends
gosh damn it
right now
it's chucky
damn it
don't worry
he's cool
is that the best way to describe it
anymore
you were
leaving your family behind like we
wouldn't notice
what family
me
devin the family you chose your trauma
family
um anyway where did this come from
um i ran to some guy at the bus station
on his way to deliver it 1987 sherwood
lane okay
why is some random guy delivering a good
guy doll
to charles lee ray's old house
ugh
i sound different he's there
what
oh
[ __ ] is that charles
it all goes down tonight
in the next episode
oh my god that's so many good guy dolls
oh no
oh
oh
chucky can just make one of these kids
successfully into a killer he's one yeah
we all knew would be junior
junior what are you doing with that
thing
oh damn
[Music]
give me that
she killed herself because she's a
quitter
jesus just like you
oh now you've done it
oh he's doing it
and you don't even need the knife
oh my god
[Music]
so he's just like spreading everywhere
yeah
like a vibrance yeah
chucky 19.
must be something with the ritual yeah
yeah thank you you have no idea how hard
it's been getting one of you little
shits to step the [ __ ] up
yeah get that head turn
oh no now
thanks to you
the real fun can start
oh damn
oh
andy
[Music]
chuckies
[Laughter]
that's right man
jesus
the next season will be an anthology
with one in every different city in
america
i knew it a set of john
says that if he gets one of them to kill
he wins it's all on now yeah that's been
part of some weird ritual
maybe
some greater voodoo curse
and then he can spread himself out
create a little army yeah leech off the
young boy's life force it's
beautiful absolutely beautiful inspiring
really
so i would love to have many me going
around
so many reactions
yes yes yes
and all of them full of reaction
single-minded in there thirst for
reaction and commentaries
back on track that was dope i really
liked it a lot like did more in the last
couple episodes
[Music]
i'm wondering where they're going with
the fly that's the one part of this
where i'm a little bit um
unsure what the direction is
where are they going on the flashbacks
because
yeah i don't really know where it's
aiming well it's just kind of just
little slices of life of like what led
to their fallout
as humans yeah i guess because yeah at
first earlier on in the series it felt
and i don't really know what i expected
at the time but it felt like yeah you
were getting these little illuminations
on the formation of charles lee ray and
i feel like you know
it makes sense to see up through when he
meets tiffany and even in this episode i
was like okay the major development is
that yeah the the sort of dysfunction in
their relationship is starting to rear
its head but it does feel like
uh the revealing momentum that the
earlier flashbacks had has kind of
petered into more of just like this is
just a fun thing that we're checking in
with here and there so yeah i i don't
know exactly if that's
leading to like a significant
punch of like here's a
formative moment for this guy because it
seems like by this point in the
flashbacks he's pretty much charlie ray
as we all know him i mean maybe it's
leading to the moment he
because in the opening of child's play
was when he went into the store
and they did the voodoo curse i had the
voodoo chant and uh
or the witchcraft chant so yeah my maybe
it's
like here's everything and then we're
going to see the moments before
that happened yeah that makes sense and
then go into that you know because yeah
i mean we're in the late 80s now so
yeah i wouldn't be surprised if
yeah i guess i wanted to know what he
was up to
but beyond that i mean i'm not saying
it's bad i just thought i'm more like i
wonder where it's going to go because i
have no idea where it's really uh
what's been the purpose of it as of late
so uh but it's been enjoyable to say the
least on on those
but i really liked uh how this is all
forming you know this is the all is lost
starting out of the soul with the
characters and
the this grievance level surprise we
didn't have a funeral for the mom
i know for protective mom especially
because the the episode i think is
titled like double the loss twice the
grief or something like that and i mean
you definitely get that for devin but
there was a moment at the wake for for
junior's mom where i was like oh that's
right you've got this for your own life
too
you know nobody didn't check it with
that at all such a clever diabolical
plan though i think what chucky has in
mind of
convincing junior's dad to
convince convincing junior that his dad
was cheating i mean this is uh
i feel like we we thought it at one
point at least which wasn't sure many of
you guys did
that he would junior would be the one he
would ultimately influence yeah i think
we i think we said something about that
so long ago
junior out of everybody like even in the
earlier episodes he he does seem to be
the one
with the like almost least amount of
power to grab at like jake is getting
bullied and stuff like that but even he
has the power sort of initially spurned
on white chucky whereas
jake is sort of at the whim of everyone
around him even lexie yeah yeah
well are not jake sorry junior junior
yeah
uh well i love it how it's all
ultimately coming together now yeah come
together i love i love to see how it's
coming together because they have the
storylines of like brie and all that and
it was kind of
it's kind of questionable like what's
the point of this storyline necessarily
in the grand scheme of it's over like i
i've always liked it
i never had any problems with it
you just when you look at like the
bigger picture it goes what is the
purpose of having this and the bigger
picture yeah
and
then you're seeing how why it is all
tied into the bigger picture yeah of why
he did kill bree in the last episode
specifically and this is all trying to
motivate one of these children into
ultimately taking a life
uh
but yeah the sinister setup of
the ploy to get junior to kill his own
father
was also shot really cool like when he
had that it was real tense you know when
junior's dad steps in there
and and the way how they're using like
the good guy doll voice before chucky's
voice comes through
but that shot when he like
he goes after hit junior then he knocks
to the wall and the camera tilts and
just stays tilted for a while and it
puts junior slightly that much more he's
already staggering but yeah he's like
towering now yeah
and then the shots of when he was
beating hell they killed him with the
good god doll yeah yeah not even the
name
yeah and that shows almost that it's
like
the knife is almost the chucky tool
where it's him just choosing
in them this is what i have on me and
i'm doing it now like it really drives
home that it's from within him yeah even
though it's influenced by chucky like it
really makes it feel like no he he chose
that what's the dad's name uh logan
logan and then lucas is yes logan lucas
well i think what they did with writing
logan was smart because
they established it's really it is cool
it's very clever writing what they've
done because they established lucas in
the beginning
who's just
obnoxiously abusive yes
you know
just every chance every moment
this bubble of cliche right yeah he's
just so awful and then he has a twin
and so immediately the association is
good guy bad guy twin and then what
they've done
over the course of this season is give
you shades of logan resembling lucas
yeah just little hints like okay he's a
he's controlling uh he it can come
through he can be aggressive he can get
defensive you know he can drink a little
much he can drink a little much there's
definitely that temper within him as
much as he tries to be more sound and
logical and be a good person his
emotions negative emotions can sometimes
get ahead of him
but they they kept him very human
and i love that they did that
because in another show or movie or
whatever this thing where where he says
something so [ __ ] mean about like
your mom died because she because he's a
quitter
would just come off as like they had to
write something so logan so junior could
kill him like that's usually how it
would probably come across like they
they just had to he had to say someone's
getting pissed drunk so he said
something [ __ ] up the movie has to
happen yeah
where that moment uh felt very natural
and in tune with the character of what
he would say
in a drunken state and really
establishing just how much of a
competitive
human that he is
like right everything that they've
talked about with junior running track
and becoming a winner becoming you know
number one
so of course you would use the
terminology if she's a quitter which has
been used for a lot of people when they
do unfortunately take their lives some
people use that sentiment but him
specifically would say that oh yeah and
so i think they did like really great
writing to earn that moment yeah
and the solid choice of leading it off
with an actual attempted compassion like
you know even though in his like the
drunk state really sells the shift of
just the id taking over but yeah i
appreciate that every step of the way
for the most part even characters that
appeared
super stereotypical from the outside
have gotten
enough flesh to drive that home and and
it's funny because i was talking to a
friend of mine last week about you know
some of the production of the older
movies and some of the woes they were
having and i mean there was a lot of
emphasis put on like
not showing chucky as much as possible
so that it doesn't get old
and like during an episode like this
it's funny it's like you called out you
know like when's chucky gonna show up
and it's like around that i feel like
they have a really great grip on
being around the time you start to think
that is when they bring him back in and
i love that the the debate that they
made of him and junior because yeah as
much as the at the beginning of their
interaction you're like
oh this is probably this has to be the
time it's going to work structurally but
it also yeah just really uh resonated
this sort of i thought his performance
uh
junior's performance was really good in
that too just you know walking that
line of being persuaded towards this and
having some of the doubts that you know
anybody might have
and then you know also to the things
with jennifer tilly and that's something
that i'm not even 100 sure about because
i'm like on the one hand this seems like
absolutely what chucky would want her to
do to seal the deal but on the other
hand i mean with like going back to the
flashbacks i almost wonder if they're
trying to motivate some kind of true
split between the two of them because
also you know she's been holding nika
hostage in nica form and things like
that
um so you know that makes me wonder but
even so in the context of junior and
logan
even that it's like we don't even know
if he's actually cheating
and obviously i mean it seems like it
would be a pretty hard thing to hide if
he's been cheating with actual jennifer
tilly all this time and he didn't really
seem to know her so you know that was
even a nice little bit of like
it's not the show yeah making that
choice of black and white like no he's
definitely a cheater it's just it's
enough doubt
to drive it all home and i feel like
that's part of the magic chucky is
exploiting those doubts and the
vulnerabilities within people based on
those doubts and yeah the way that he's
able to to craft this web is diabolical
it's really fun to see play out in long
form
because you know like the the the best
of the chucky movies do that to an
extent but to see it really kind of cast
in this broad web is kind of fascinating
yeah
yeah that's most interesting part i mean
everything with junior and i mean jake
is cool yeah you know you feel bad you
hope they'll come back together at some
point
and devin's kidnapped i don't know
what's gonna happen there so what's the
plan here is there's gonna be a bunch of
chuckies right roman yeah it's just
gonna be an army of chucks all right
guys look i'm still recovering a little
bit i just seen an ass do i have like
snot on my face i don't know
fast like a few minutes i've been like
do i it's not just like fall out as i
told you to blow my nose
dude it would rise up instead of me like
oh let me look in the mirror just ask
josh right now because he just felt like
the felt like [ __ ] i feel like that's
not my face the whole time i'm talking
about it
i just got the warm breath condensation
uh yeah no this was uh
it was a solid and you and
everything that's happening with devin
and junior is a great way to
to write them be torn apart
um i guess they're gonna [ __ ] do
batman returns this [ __ ] with all the
penguins that's gonna be a bunch of
chuckies
and then everyone's just gonna converge
on the lee ray house you know yeah
final showdown
ah
all if they just killed chucky in the
end in the last episode i know
i don't know how i feel if it goes a
little if it's going to be a little too
big
i'm very curious i'm cautious i'm
cautious about that because i like the
personal
one-on-one entanglement but there's like
there's like a chucky everywhere it's
well yeah
that's what's funny to me is is that
prospect because i know that one of the
woes of like child's play too was like
the original vision was to try and do
like show as much chucky as possible and
have tons and tons of chucky and like it
seems like
using chucky sparingly is part of what
makes it work
and uh yeah i'm really curious too
because they seem very committed to
their puppetry like there's been some
cgi across the show here and there to
sweeten things but it seems very married
to that and i can imagine on the one
hand seeing some really impressive like
puppetry gags if they have a bunch of
them
uh but also yeah i don't want it to be
like just the episode where there's like
it's like a chucky everywhere and
there's no tension yeah you know but i i
have faith that they'll make it
i mean that first shot of him waking up
and just seeing how many there were did
give me that like oh no kind of feeling
so it's scary
in uh concept yeah it's a scary concept
yeah but yeah i hope it doesn't get too
too big
just big enough yeah otherwise we're
gonna see a bunch of cgi or
child actors
yes yes we're gonna get little people
stunt performers and uh and cgi
everywhere it's usually a combination of
little people or child actors yeah they
are child stunt men yeah some performers
uh
less violent gags that's just the funny
part about it is because they don't
check chucky moves like a doll yeah
absolutely so whatever they do these
like sideways shots or behind shots i'm
like it's just clearly like a an actual
human yeah yeah chucky's closer
articulation there's not even any
direction and
kind of move like a puppy yeah
yeah
make it seem like a puppet you're just
moving like a like a regular person
yeah yeah
uh yeah that's a great episode man great
episode uh definitely better
in my mind it's i hate it much better
than the last two personally
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell hit that
like button oh we rested up for that
[ __ ] finale hey we should probably do
a
brian perry thank you so much for being
part of our patreon page you're gonna
get a classic shout out today
because it's your first one
b
stands for
bitcoin because you're going to make a
killing
bitcoin
yeah
and r stands for
resilient because you know brian perry
like your name just brings me a sense of
light and uh and you know ingenuity and
longevity i'm inspired
you y
for
yellow because you make me feel warm and
you still haven't learned that that is
an inappropriate slang
for a certain group of people
out there you got to stop doing that
brian
absolutely and to that point o stands
for onion cause you're a layered person
and hey maybe you peel back that racist
layer but the rest of it is all
beautiful and worth maintaining nice
n is for nice
this is very nice because at the end of
the day if you're here at our patreon
page
it's because
you're a nice guy
too nice
stop maybe you should have pledged
somewhere else yeah
take that niceness to a place where it
could be more appreciated instead of
getting a sarcastic shout out instead of
being here
you racist against chinese people right
love you buddy thank you
[Music]